welcome back the trollsnews not a lot up
than the last 24 hours you know just
conor mcgregor smash up a bus full of
UFC fighters yeah yeah yeah that's it
really big liverpool fun yeah but
couldn't make another man city game so
you thought just to show you support
you smash up any little bus what no one
seems to be grasped it is why this has
all happened you know everyone seeing
the footage and gone on like a maniac
and mainstream media who don't pay
attention to UFC are mm II just Brian
I'm an absolute nut case which he is but
we need to know why he might be on cork
either he's clean John I mean I want him
on the podcast one day so he's
definitely clean so autumn liubov who's
Conor McGregor's best man train
important I went on a Russian YouTube
channel did an interview way said a few
things about khabib nurmagomedov so in
the interview autumn talked about khabib
and said that he's a constant Paul out
moocher assume he's a little bit injured
he's out of the fight then he doesn't
even make weight off that I meet he's
missed like six UFC fights or something
like that now so the man has a point but
he did call him a chicken and if there's
anything we've learned from partner the
future
you don't call another manager in
particular autumn said the khabib
doesn't care about the funds because of
how many times the Russia people are
coming over to support him and he's just
not there and in by comparison Conor
even when he has a massive knee injury
or all these other problems like he's
had all these terms up now we know
what's happened in the last couple years
with Amir with our money but that is
kind of true as well so now Waterman
khabib are fighting on the same card at
UFC 223 and of course the bull mint of
each other the walk through the lobby
the difference is is autumn Labov is on
his own and khabib is mobbed up with a
lord of daghestani lads with him and
they call industry of forum kabir grabs
a hold of the back of the net as he's
talking to him he's right in his face
and he said you're gonna call us a
chicken now where's Connor now and
autumn like any smart and sensible lad
would do didn't react you've got the
[__] out of there as quick as he could
and some of these daghestani lads do not
[__] around they've been not to get MMA
fight as in night clubs they have you
stun guns on fighters so Otto did the
right thing getting the [__] out of
there but Conor McGregor watched this
footage and he was ragin takes 20
minutes has a cup of tea you know still
ragin looks outside sunny weather
I saw that still [__] ragin checks
his bun balance hundred million quid in
the back still raging goes for a [__]
one flush all gone nailed it
still region D makes him his favorite
sandwich still ragin goes to the gym
spends an hour in the heavy bag takes
all his anger out he's taken feel better
now gets in the car
still ragin has a look in his closet all
the beautiful suits he's trying them
what he's doing everything to make
himself feel better but still raging
goes to sleep that night slips right the
way through like a baby wakes up in the
morning feels a little better sees the
clip again ragin gives us me a ring come
round lads gonna need to talk you I'm
ragin not gonna dog friends are there
opens it still raging what's the problem
Connor you know the world's your oyster
mate you've got everything what more
could you need and yet you're all wound
up because someone's gone on telly
smacking me around saying where's Connor
making it look like it's your fault what
are you worried about why your ragin
still raging Crocs have bought Luqman
with a lot ticks a beautiful silky
smooth sip of notorious whiskey but
still raging you gets the fallout
they're all getting excited Brook in the
private jet isn't he where we're going
Connor and beefer Magaluf yeah Italy no
Cortland New York I'm Rachel can I stop
what you do in the same put the phone
down there's no point in doing that it
doesn't make sense Connor for a start
that's 15 over here and it's 10 miler
check you're gonna need to private jets
if you wanna go over there and beat them
up
ether agent so he's booked the Jets the
airport so so he's on the way at the
airport now and at no point has he
calmed down and he's sitting there
watching the Instagram video on loop of
low Bob getting slapped by khabib ragin
get on the private jet cut then goes to
shake his hand walked right past them
[__] Regent they put his dinner out
for him it's lovely
Rajon puts on the complimentary for
jobless sits and Hussey's dinner it's
perfect
still Rachel 7 our fight constantly
still watching on loop yeah absolutely
region lands in Europe by this point
it's two days since row Bob got slapped
in a lobby by khabib
still region mix it over the Atlantic
record time
seven hours north turbulence perfect
touchdown smooth line and that the
platelets given himself a pat on the
back there
the Irishman on board hey Connor sitting
there not a word
still ragin orders Anubha it's there
within three minutes fantastic Pop's
himself in a lovely little Toyota a
bottle of dashi fella as they wit with a
four point eight nine rating promises
Connor a five star fantastic
he's got the conversation to drive and
race your meal down put it this way it
was a quiet journey but he gets Connor
there in perfect time nor traffic in New
York Conor McGregor still rigid now he's
gettin hungry so he gets out the uber
one of the members of the media lets him
in the back door to the arena gets in
the elevator manages to get himself to
the carpark
finds the bus that has khabib
nurmagomedov on it runs towards it picks
up the nearest object just so happens to
be here massive reel and smashes that
through the window could be born get off
wasn't a stop mate
so he's paid two dollars for that ticket
and we all know Russians are thrifty so
but nothing to do with the 20 Irishman
who want to kill him yeah Russians are
thrifty now he's on the run from the
NYPD but the main thing to remember here
is Conor McGregor feels bad just [__]
up this whole life like but it's not
Richard anymore every cloud so now what
happens well he could end up doing jail
time he's probably gonna get sued by
kids are the fighter who ended up with
lacerations to the face his visa could
be revoked so he can't fight in America
anymore he's definitely going to be
fined by the UFC he could even be
released by the USA but we all know
that's not gonna happen let's face it
John Jones got away with crashing into a
pregnant woman while on drugs and
running from the scene so I think Connor
is probably gonna get away with this
however it's not a good look is it just
signed a deal with beats for Christ's
sake I mean they're not gonna be loving
this but jørgen always says when you get
wild [__] like John Jones
they've got greatness in them but
there's also chaos and this is Conor
McGregor's chaos this is what you get
them from right
now and I'm not excused in anything he
does but I'm seeing the outcry from the
public oh my god he's acting like a kid
he's acting like a maniac and I'm taking
him he cell he grew up wanting a fight
in a steel cage like I mean let's not
get surprised when he does it in a car
park I'm not excusing what he's done
he's a [__] idiot and he's got a kid
at home whom he should be setting a
better example for and while I
understand his anger for what the
protect is me
you can be khabib nurmagomedov in a cage
and take the title away from him
humiliate him and do it in front of
everyone and do it 1v1 why do this now
and Bruce getting yourself look look
when you've got a son at home and I
don't get it I understand the younger
but Conor McGregor's normally such a
calculated methodical man and this is
wild even for him and as a fan of Conor
McGregor it's been ages since we've seen
him in the cage doing what he does best
which is Mme I don't want to see him
boxing I don't want to see him in a car
park fight I want him in a cage with a
belt on the lane showing the skills I
hear us because for all the the talk and
everything else in the boxing and the
razzmatazz the man's actually a
world-class mixed martial artist what is
then I went to next probably internally
he'll be grateful because Conor McGregor
has just gave in UFC 223 all the
promotion it was missing because now
everyone's gonna want to see what
happens with khabib because khabib is
fighting for Conor's title and he's just
being stripped off if he wins that you
[__] know he's going to call out
Conor and then we've got the fight of
the [__] century Mahan's in the UFC
because we finally got someone who is
coming up against Conor McGregor who
could potentially dominate him and a bad
bad way
it's disgusting and I don't think
anybody is gonna be in
huge Conor McGregor fans after this DNR
White House to stick with corner to a
degree while publicly criticized him in
turn you know they're gonna try and look
after him he is the money pot but the
quicker we get Connor out of this
[__] jail cell and back into a cage
and live in a fight as life instead of a
multimillionaires life the better so
that's all I've got to say on the matter
for now I'm sure this is gonna run on
and on so if you want to know what I
think as this develops subscribe to the
true Johnny YouTube channel hit the
[__] like button thanks for watching
and I'll say as later